let's talk dancing with the stars now
because it's just three days until its
streaming debut and our matt cohen
caught up with season 31's new hosting
duo tyra banks and alfonso rivero who
already have some fresh history
oh my god will
alfonso was like this it was a weird
warmth that i felt with you but i also
felt like a brother that i would like
tease right
now we had fun really like first day oh
absolutely you know most people don't
realize is that we actually went to
middle school together yeah so like
there was also no but he was like a
really big celebrity he didn't know i
existed
how did this partnership come about you
obviously have chemistry yeah so with
the with the um edition of disney plus
there's a whole new way of doing the
show and it's it's impossible to host
the show alone it is it is impossible
based on no commercials and needing to
clear the sets they said one name to me
and i was like stop
right there now alfonso i want to ask
you about this we love watching you on
america's funniest now you're on dancing
with the stars you've you've kind of uh
gone in tom's footsteps a little bit i'm
actually in a time right now i'm like
tom needs to get another big show
because when afb and dancing with the
stars end i need another job that i need
to go get
right
as for the competitors only e.t was at
disneyland with the pros as they shot
the opening number we'll see on monday's
premiere four five six seven eight
this is so exciting to be in disneyland
for the opening number i wish my little
boy was here to experience this with me
there really is magic in the air we
brought back louie we brought back mark
i mean they are legends of the ballroom
peter murgatroyd who's teamed up with
sex and the city's jason lewis also
returned to the dance floor after taking
a season off jason's doing amazing he's
got confidence he's giving me all that
determination that i need jordan has all
the energy in the world she's super
excited to be here and that's really all
you need is a little bit of spirit and
maybe a little bit of dance ability what
she has so we're happy wayne is so sweet
and he can move but we're getting those
hips loose we're very competitive and
we're in it to win it
[Music]